نحن هنا في مخيم النصيرات وسط قطاع غزه
قصفت الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه هذا
المسجد الذي نقف على انقاضه لكن الدمار
كان كبيرا جل المنازل التي تقع في هذا
المربع السكني دمرت بالكامل سويت بالارض
عشرات من الشهداء والجرحى سقطوا جراء هذه
الغاره التي استهدفت هذا المسجد لكن
الدمار كبير في كل المنازل المحيطه ليس
اضرار انها دمار بشكل كبير وبالتالي هناك
عشرات من الشهداء والجرحى سقطوا من بينهم
اطفال كانوا يلعبون في هذه في هذه المنطقه
لكن بعض من هذه العائلات الفلسطينيه تقوم
الان بعمليات ترميم لهذه المنازل عملا في
ان تعود اليها او يعود من تبقى حيا الى
هذه المنازل دعونا نرى
ونستطيع
شايفينكم بتغط في بيت وبتغطي في الامور
يعني في بتحاولوا يعني تنظفوا ولا ايش
تعملوا والله احنا قاعدين بنظف في البيت
على اساس في اخوي عنده اولاده بقوا نايمين
في الدار امنين ما لقوا ل الصاروخ نزل هنا
دمر البيت عنده مراته لاخوي استشهدت بنته
استشهدت اولاده تصاوب وهم نايمين ناس ما
لناش الا الله هم هلقيت مشردين لانه انت
شافت جوو المدارس مليانه ما فيش بده يروح
بده يتبهدل وين يتشح شط مع لسه ضيل عنده
بناته واجوازهم وعائلاتهم وما لهم الا
الله احنا لمين نتوجه الشهداء اللي راحوا
الاطفال كل الدنيا وين يروحوا هذول الناس
الحمد لله على سلامتكم ربنا يعينكم يا رب
اذا هذا هو الحال في مخيم النصيرات لكنه
يتشابه في كل المناطق الفلسطينيه مدارس
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين ومدارس النجو التي
لجا اليها السكان ممتلئه عن بكره ابيها
وال مساعدات قليله وهناك شح في كل شيء
المواد التموينيه والمياه وبالتالي بات
القطاع على شفا كارثه انسانيه وصحيه
وبيئيه من كل الجوانب هشام زقوت الجزيره
من مخيم النصيرات وسط قطاع غزه فلسطين